well hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba
this is shemitah sorry Buffett bought it
Bhattacharya but no what is it yeah if
you have come from the Jeb Ocoee channel
my brother from the same mother he had a
short meeting on a few times I collab
wisher meetha there and I said sure Mita
you gotta come on the real rejects we're
way better and get way less views so you
got to be here you and I have had
experiences with reading negative
comments mmm-hmm but can you imagine
what it's like for a celebrity to read
mean things about you on the Internet
Jimmy Kimmel Live is celebrities reading
mean tweets means entertainment for us
entertainment for us that's right one
day I want to tweet a celebrity
something mean and see if they read it
Jimmy Kimmel how cool would that be
that's a good thing now people actually
try yeah okay let's see what the meanest
things are that people have to say and
let's see if we agree with any of them
[Applause]
good girl imma imma imma I am ma is that
a word
I must be wondering why that woman got
no titties yeah they're here we don't
worry yeah Emma Watson seems like the
type of girl where I be friends with for
like three days and then get really sick
of her I think she can clean up well
despite my grandmother's harsh opinion
that she's hideous
oh I bet the John Lithgow's ballsack
looks exactly like his face my face is
not complimented by Jeffrey Tambor to me
that's just hurtful
in what if Paltrow just stick to
sustaining her vagina and shut flower
gets its big break cuz it's like I have
a bag of flour like a ventriloquist
dummy became the wife to become a sex
offender she's like it seems like the
kind of person I'd be thrilled to be
paired up with for a school project but
then would never want to hang out with
her otherwise what no I love her hate
this person someone just told me I
smiled like Michael Keaton and I don't
know if I should take 1 million selfies
or put a gun in my mouth just
unwatchable totally biased not funny
Baldwin impersonation just can't get any
worse multiple colors yes every shade of
your mom's lips Wow great comeback
great Wow Camille's comeback was early I
wonder if that was at all plan right
because I know he gets background and
improv and all that if someone could be
quick enough to come up with it he does
have he seems to give really good tweets
and stuff like responses to people have
you ever seen him perform live I've seen
him at the Comedy Store
he's hysterical is it great I just all
the big sick yeah I just saw that which
was the first time I kind of saw him in
an on call like he was so funny yeah but
they had a little bit more of like drama
in there and up until then he just
fighting yeah he is you know I love
about these celebrities especially for
you know like you're an aspiring actress
you gotta build your social media I do
YouTube you never know which one's gonna
be full of just mean nastiness plenty of
people say mean things about me one time
actually try doing a video like a
segment of a video where I was trying to
read all the mean comments yeah but like
95% of them are actually really nice but
there was a period where is like
primarily mean comments and it's nice to
see the shift it is at that point in my
my comments on a video usually less than
1% of the people who watch actually
comment and be you don't know who any of
these people are and I think what makes
these comments sometimes worse someone's
hate comment about me I'm not hearing
their tone of voice I don't know what
they look like I don't know what Asia
are I don't know a gender they are
probably a guy but I don't know who they
are but I'm putting a voice of it in my
own head that sounds worse and I think
it's like my mom and dad say you know
you know what it is all these people who
write these things I'm thinking about
their ex right yeah you triggered
something oh you guys need to get over
it you know bond in the better world or
rebound rebound and don't commit ever
again never open up your heart to
another person life advice it's things
like this that just make me love
Jennifer Lawrence even more the way she
plays along with me with hate you know I
feel like she's someone who can just
deal with with hatred she's just a
likeable girl next door but she's really
super famous
and better than all of us yet she's so
relatable Kristen Bell why she used to
be my crush she still is my crush she's
still your crush really I watch the good
place you see the new anyways anyways I
just like her I just really like her I
like her I like her spirit
she's just seems like she's a genuine
person do you see all the stuff about
her like during hurricane Harvey and
like singing to all the people who were
stranded in the hotel she did that oh I
didn't know that she's my crush now
again I used to daydream that I could
meet her become a successful actor and
then start dating her husband but he's a
pervert is he
I've seen his brand of comedy and I that
tells you everything
and also gal gadot she needs to stop
getting hate comments about her
breasticles man yeah that was just like
I was like someone's just really that's
that's the ex that's her accent yeah I
missed them so I'm I to grade them how
horrible do you have to be i mama yeah
cuz cuz of her here's a bit sweet oh I
get it your that's what they call
brilliance and callback in comedy yeah
well done charlie it's upsetting because
like how perfect do you expect someone
to be she's already beautiful she
already is a superstar a talented
actress she's physically fit but now
you're just gonna attack her on her
boobs no man no I mean she had bigger
boobs that would be cool but come on
accept her I love you gal gadot ewwww
well guys this is our video and it is
complete today you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell but more importantly I would like
it if you could follow
charmita Matakana guy
but about a matter chharia Beccaria you
got it than you did good uh-huh that's
that's like every girl I've ever
approached that tells me that you had me
but then you lost it halfway